it's a very harsh weather out here very
unpredictable takes a lot of time and
effort to have everything ready for the
winter
ready yeah go pull up maybe uh pull the
side on first this way
going uh
this is the sled I'm going to be working
on so we can have something to carry all
our equipment and stuff down in the
beach
okay I've been working on it for a while
since my last school year I just
graduated last year and really good to
have these things ready before winter
comes
it would be really hard without this
okay uh get the skills off see if we can
cut out the
three inches off yeah try to get two on
each side that way it'll be thick enough
to use throughout the winter
I've seen in a sewer pipe playing
be good for uh Fred Runners they just
play around for years after being
replaced
everything is hard to get out here
you know in a remote Village whenever we
can get a hold of we try to hold on to
try not to waste anything
[Music]
let's see you so see if it works
for the evening it out and uh
looks good huh yeah
how much uh sticking out got about an
inch uh to work with let's put
[Music]
right after this garage was built I put
in my wood stove that I made at school
last year
I've been working on a lot of things in
here
growing up my dad taught me how to make
things
oh we're gonna put bolts on the front
end there to secure the sled
there's a little wish and then couldn't
go in an angle this way
yeah you hit a screw and tried in here I
think
down
[Music]
hey
we're in business
yeah can't wait to see this uh brand new
sledding use I know these floods are
hard to come by
hey time for uh kumara yeah you know
winter time is just around the corner
getting colder and windier that's a
little bit harder to hunt from Land put
it under there but I have a sled looking
for the game
Wars
what else
and all the other marine mammals that
come along the ice they're going to be
plentiful
hey part of these different parts of the
house to bend it
and perversion the depth
hey we're done
go we're in business the weather has
been a big factor
and we've had a poor season this past
year
we've got to prepare for it
you gotta take what life gives you
try to make adjustments
basically go with the weather
shouldn't be too long to finish it now
yeah
[Music]
thank you